now Pearl Skin studio the sponsors of
this segment is back to tell us how they
cannot help you with not just your face
but help you your entire body shine
bright like a diamond Katya welcome back
thank you for having us again you look
beautiful I am loving this outfit thank
you Mother's Day is coming you know huh
so our mother so happy Mother's Day to
you thank you thank you yeah we're here
with diamond glow for the body we used
to do face only and now we brought the
body treatment it's evolved because you
can't neglect all the other parts no no
especially bathing suit is coming you
know it's Sunday it's hot for Mother's
Day we have a pool party and in order
for you to get your body ready for
swimming season it's great to have
Diamond glow because it exfoliates and
infuses vitamins into the skin
currently he's infusing hyaluronic acid
in her skin and hyaluronic acid is the
volume for the skin so it makes it full
and smooth also the body skin on the
body tends to look dry and Flaky
especially here in Vegas especially yeah
elasticity is not so so and cellulite is
the number one country so this helps
with cellulite oh that's yeah to know
that's good to know it provides
lymphatic drainage again infuses
vitamins deep to the dermis this is the
only machine on the market that can
claim that it's infusion of the vitamins
to the dermis wow and I know how that
feels on your face so I can just imagine
how it feels on the body now Chrissy
Teigen yeah
celebrities love this procedure yes so
um tell everybody what the process is
when they come in so when they come in
they just choose the part of the body
that they want to do they can do the
whole body in the face or they can pick
and choose that's because you know yeah
it can be done on the leg on the legs to
improve cell light and hydration it can
be done on the buttocks it can be done
on the back because a lot of people have
breakouts on the back it's great for
that it can be done for KP on the back
of the arms you know the texture
breakouts of course chest right because
decollete has a lot of sun damage yeah
yeah because it takes care of the
pigmentation as well absolutely yeah now
I know this the diamond glow you want to
shine bright like a diamond but there's
also a very special reason why this is
called The Diamond glow explain that
yeah because it has special little tip
right here and it has little cross
diamonds inside so this is what actually
exfoliates the skin luxury otherwise it
exfoliates it infuses vitamins at the
same time that's incredible now how
quickly do you see results immediately
it's immediate okay the skin smooth like
velvet like Silk I'm ready I'm ready now
you have you have a special to tell
everybody about right yes yeah every
time you book Diamond glow you get 30
off get ready for mother day guys yes
get your gifts ready it's perfect gift
for the mother or for anyone absolutely
and you take care of us so I hope you're
taking care of yourself this week of
course all right thank you Pearl Skin
studio for sponsoring this segment call
702-525-5504 or visit
pearlskinstudio.com for more information
they will have that special offer for
you and it's 30 off your diamond glow
I'll send it to you Kendall